صوت الغضب يصدح في مختلف ارجاء باريس
الجاليه الكرديه في العاصمه الفرنسيه
تواصل التمديد بهجوم الدائره العاشره الذي
اودى بحياه ثلاثه افراد قتلا بالرصاص
لكنها تتجنب اشعال فتى للعنف متظاهروا
الجاليه الكرديه في باريس قرروا انهاء
مسيره لهم تمديدا لهجوم باريس انهوها بشكل
مبكر تجنبا لاي اعمال شغب الجلسه الاولى
من محاكمه المتهم صنعت الاحداث بشكل موازن
منفذ الهجوم ادلب اعترافات مثيره كشفت
نزعته لعنصريه وزاره العدل اعلنت عن جزء
من اعترافته حيث اكد انه يشعر برغبه في
قتل مهاجرين اجانب وذلك منذ تعرض منزله
للسطو في عام 2016
المتهم اعترف ايضا انه ناقم على كل
المهاجرين معبرا عن شعوره بالغضب تجاه
الاكراد لانهم اثروا مقاتلين اثناء
محاربتهم داعش بدلا من تصفياتهم على حد
تعبيرهم اللافه الذين انه ابدى ندمه على
انه لم يقتل عددا اكبر
وبعد اعترافاته لعنصريه هذه تم اصدار
لائحه الاتهام بحق المتهم بقتل الاكراد
حيث اوضح مصدر قضائي ان منفذ هجوم باريس
وهو سائق قطار متقاعد يحمل الجنسيه
الفرنسيه وجه له قاضي التحقيق تهم القتل
ومحاوله القتل على اساس العرق او الاثنيه
او البلدي او الدين مفضلا او فضلا عن
اتهامه بالحصول على اسلحه وحيازتها دون
رخصه
[موسيقى]